bonsoir rony brauman merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france je voulais
revenir avec vous sur les déclarations
du chef de l'état un investissement
massif dans l'hôpital après la crise la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
pour le personnel de santé et des primes
pour les médecins votre votre réaction
quand à ces annonces du chef de l'état
on ne peut pas être contre le fait de
mieux valoriser financièrement le
travail des hospitaliers qui ont qui est
effectivement essentiel qui est
primordial et avec les pertes que l'on
vient de déplorer qu'on entre vient de
signaler l'existence là
cette difficulté les risques qui sont
pris le l'intensité du travail
l'importance de ce rôle sont soulignés
et de là dessus je n'ai évidemment
aucune critique bien au contraire je
trouve que c'est important mais vous le
disiez un instant le problème il se
trouve ailleurs
également il se trouve dans le manque de
moyens dans la l'austérité dans laquelle
sont plongés les hôpitaux et le système
de santé français depuis longtemps
austérité qui n'a jamais été prise en
compte lorsque les personnels
hospitaliers protestait se révoltaient
manifestaient et qui d'un seul coup
aujourd'hui devient un problème
il était temps tu m'aimes on peut dire
que s'il était même plus que temps par
ailleurs au début de ce mois avant la
prise de parole du président on le
voyait muni d'un masque entouré de gens
qui étaient masqués vous posiez la
question de savoir s'il y avait une
symbolique
oui sans doute il ya une symbolique mais
elle est à double tranchant cette
symbolique
on nous explique d'un côté que les
masques ne servent à rien et je pense
que pour la plupart des gens qui sont
pas en contact avec le grand public dans
des contacts répétés et rapproché c'est
peut être tout à fait défendable mais il
n'empêche que là on n'est pas dans une
situation de contacts rapprochés et
pourtant tout le monde portent des
masques de la même façon que les tests
sont paraît-il utile uniquement pour les
malades graves
hospitalisé et on apprend que des
parlementaires des ministres et
secrétaires d'état se sont fait tester
alors qu'ils ne sont ni est dans une
situation grave ni hospitalisées dont
captif des passe-droits il ya t'il des
privilèges applique-t-on ici une mesure
qu'on refuse ailleurs il ya là des
contradictions qui sont graves et
lorsque j'entends le président nous a
appelés à faire bloc dans l'unité
nationale et cela à plusieurs reprises
dans le cadre d'une guerre menée au
virus
là je m'inquiète parce que faire bloc ça
veut dire marché en marche en avant
marcher au pas d'une certaine manière
puisque on est en guerre et c'est la
dernière des choses à faire de marcher
au pas d'indiscrétion aussi complexe
dans une situation aussi massive que ça
nous avons besoin non pas de polémique
comme le mot a été prononcé à plusieurs
reprises qui est assez désobligeant pour
le débat mais de discussion de
controverses toutes les vérités ne tombe
pas du ciel tout équipé iliad est
nécessaire débat devant une situation
qui est tout à fait inédite donc plus
d'ouverture à différentes possibilités
et puis un par les plus vrai par exemple
disons reconnaissons franchement que
l'état d'impréparation dans lequel nous
nous trouvions faisait que la mise à
disposition des tests n'étaient pas
possibles que par ailleurs des goulots
d'étranglement dans la production
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur sur ces
tests 1 puisque le ministre de la santé
a annoncé hier vouloir multiplier par
trois le nombre de tests donc de passer
de 9 mille tests quotidiens à 29 mille
tests pourquoi avoir attendu mais c'est
à eux qu'il faut le demander
tous les gens qui ont affaire à des
épidémies savent que la question du
diagnostic de la mède qui permet
l'isolément des patients qui sont
potentiellement dangereux à la fois pour
le personnel soignant et pour les autres
patients dans les hôpitaux est
absolument essentiel est par ailleurs le
testing disons-le à la pratiquer des
tests large a montré son efficacité en
chine à hong kong
en corée du sud est préconisée par
l'immense majorité des médecins s'il ya
un consensus dans ce domaine c'est bien
dans l'élargissement des pratiques de
dépistage biologique c'est à dire la
mise en oeuvre des tests à la fois les
tests sérologiques et les tests
immunologiques je rentrerai pas dans le
détail ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
l'endroit mais enfin il y a des moyens
ils ne sont pas encore mis à la
disposition et on peut comprendre qu' on
ne peut pas d'un seul coup passé de
quelques centaines à quelques dizaines
de milliers de tests par jour ça demande
du temps mais qu qu'on nous dise cela
plutôt que de nous expliquer que ça n'a
aucun intérêt si on dit quelque chose de
cet ordre et que d'un seul coup on
s'aperçoit que l'intérêt finalement il
est résistant comme en inspirer la
confiance comment arriver à cet état de
nudité dont parle le chef de l'état donc
oui les tests sont indispensables leur
pratique leur utilisation doit être
élargi de façon massive et aussi rapide
que possible
de même que l'usagé des masques au moins
pour tous les gens qui sont en contact
soit avec des patients pour les
soignants mais avec du public qu'on soit
policier caissiers caissières enfin bref
dans des rapports avec le reste des gens
qui sont répétés et rapprochés on nous
disait que ça servait à rien maintenant
on s'aperçoit que ça sert à quelque
chose
rony brauman j'aimerais évoquer avec
vous à prendre avant de nous quitter un
dernier thème celui du confinement vous
le savez la france est confinée depuis
un peu plus d'une semaine maintenant
et certaines voix commencent à s'élever
mesure qui pourrait selon certains
bafouer nos libertés individuelles et
publiques
est ce que est ce que vous pensez que
c'est le cas et à tant d'autres
solutions je pense que ces deux risques
mais en effet faute de mieux le
confinement reste la solution de repli
mais ce n'est qu'une supposition est une
solution que provisoire et envoie déjà
en chine par exemple haouran les
difficultés de lever le confinement
disons les mesures restrictives en
général du fait du risque d'un rebond
épidémie d'où l'importance d'avoir à la
fois des structures de soins mais la
possibilité à nouveau de tester de
manière à isoler ceux qui doivent l'être
mais a laissé circuler ce qu'ils peuvent
circuler et donc là aussi la levée du
confinement va être tributaire de la
mise à disposition des tests et la façon
dont on envisage sera différente alors
de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui en
l'absence totale de test mais par
ailleurs pour répondre à l'autre partie
de votre question oui je crois que cet
état d'urgence sanitaire qui a sans
doute un certain nombre de raisons
d'être doit être pris avec beaucoup de
prudence on l'histoire nous montre que
lorsqu'on prend des mesures restrictives
des mesures d'exception
elles finissent par s'installer dans
l'ordinaire de la vie et a confié à
l'exécutif à la police à
l'administration d'aidé des pouvoirs
régaliens qui ne sont pas partagées qui
peuvent être appliqués dans bien
d'autres domaines on l'avait vu au
moment des manifestations de gilet jaune
dans bien d'autres domaines que ceux
pour lesquels elle avait été prévu je
rappelle que des lois antiterroristes
ont été appliquées à des militants
écologistes qui n'étaient en rien des
terroristes en puissance donc
naturellement il faut des mesures
d'exception car il ya une situation
exceptionnelle merci merci beaucoup
remis à brauman d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france rappelle que vous
êtes un médecin spécialiste de médecine
tropicale et épidémiologiques ancien
président de médecins sans frontières
merci beaucoup